yo what up it's your boy baldacci the
beast face of los angeles for music make
sure to check me out on the bootleg kev
podcast
boom boo lay cat podcast special guest
man we got the homie baldacci in the
building much love much love welcome man
yes sir welcome brother how's uh first
of all you got um you got a lot of stuff
you've been working on man you just
showed me you got some your own hemp
raps coming out with the album filling
their hand brass new album coming out
um
for people who don't know your story man
just kind of give me like a quick
breakdown like where you're from
i'm from i'm from south la florence
district you know born and raised grown
you know i was born in englewood
california brought to a street called
converse which that's my block there we
basically
turned into our block basically and it's
uh
it's um it's in florence area you know
what i mean like that's that's where i
was basically raised at
um that's why you see i got a converse
all star on my hand because i'm
literally a all-star from the block you
know
only a couple of us have that
um
in and out of the system let's get that
mic right here in the middle just so we
can get make sure in and out of the
system you know back and forth dealing
with you know whatever came with
me being in that area growing up in that
area and part of you know what i mean
the gang and stuff like that i was
back and forth in jail but
i i made the best out of it you know
after several years of being in and out
of the system i just decided to you know
go fly the right way and try to make
something of myself that at the end of
the day it's not
you know nothing negative it's turning
the negative into a positive basically
with my music do you um well first of
all when was the last like when did you
get out last um so originally i paroled
from the federal system in 2011
close to 2012.
um
i was dealing with probation probation
was real hard for me because i had
people giving me record deals and that i
couldn't sign
um because of the probation the
probation wouldn't let me sign anything
that that wasn't
like somebody saying hey here's 50 000
we're gonna put you to
work in the studio he's like you know
i've had several
people come through this through through
here and basically say oh i got a record
deal oh but if they're not offering
money because a lot of those record
deals were saying hey we're gonna um
attempt to make money with
so with that he was like you know i've
had a lot of that go on and where i went
to the studios and i pull up and it's
just a bunch of dudes smoking weed and i
have recording
so okay you know i had to roll with the
punches and deal with that probation and
the only way i was going to be able to
get off that probation
was me doing violations to get it done
faster and that's what i did because i
couldn't travel
couldn't leave you know it was just
one it was a one-track thing for me and
if i didn't have a
a studio or a label paying me then i had
to have a job
so i had to go with the whole job thing
for a little while and it was just you
know it was it was rough it wasn't easy
how long ago did you get off probation
um i got off probation i want to say
2016.
it's crazy because
i feel like they
you know if you're
out and you're trying to make something
of yourself like that probation is kind
of like it's kind of like an invisible
jail right like it's a way to keep you
in the system like it definitely held me
back from a lot you know it was so many
opportunities that had risen and that
were presented to me that i wasn't able
to
capitalize on and i wasn't able to jump
on you know what i'm saying and it's
like
where when when we're sitting here
trying to get something positive done
like i feel like that should be allowed
you know what i mean that should be
respected and appreciated rather than
to trying to keep you in that
that hole
that you just climbed out of you know by
me getting off probation i felt like i
climbed out of a hole you know because
it took so long it was you know bobbing
and weaving and still having one foot in
and one foot out music and still being
on the streets like that was not easy at
all um
over overall like over your life how
many years were you incarcerated man i
got locked up when i was 13 years old
um
and you know in and out i'd say it just
oh man from 13 to
what 15 or something like that and then
from
16 to 18 and then from 18 to 24
from 24
until i was 32 i believe or something
like that like it just was
i gave them a lot of years of my life
you know what i mean it's hard for me to
just say one number only because i did
do small violations in between
six months here three months there eight
months they're like you know it's just
hard to calculate all of that unless you
sit down and really say hey and which
there's dates that i was in the system
that i don't even remember that's crazy
because it was so much you know i just i
was flipping calendars
yo it's crazy because uh both of my
cousins who
want them still in prison one of us
passed away they had the calendar
tattoos with all right all the years
yeah i feel like that's a common thing
right i never did that because i would
have had that going down my whole arm
that's crazy you know what i mean i
would have needed more room for that
like i just
you had a room anyway yeah you're right
i mean i got a little bit of room like
on my legs and stuff but other than that
my body's filled up back
chest facing as you guys see you know um
you know with the prison thing like
obviously
you know there's
different politics
in prison than outside of prison would
you say is that accurate um you know i
feel like everywhere you go
you know you step on the metro they have
rules you know what i mean you step on a
bus in the street they have everywhere
you go you're gonna deal with rules
that's just part of the part of life
um
you know
when you get to where you're going
you figure out what's going on and
that's
basically how we roll you know what i'm
saying it's like i don't i don't
really
how can i explain i don't
like
practice or or you know any of that i
just wherever i get to i'm at
i basically
you know
try to roll with the punches and roll
with what's going on and just go the
right direction just fly a straight kite
you know
would you say like a because you know
there's i feel like when you're
locked up when you're incarcerated
usually there's like
every group of people has like a shot
caller somebody kind of helps
you know maybe kind of navigate who's
who's coming in who's coming out like
hey help navigate the the politics or
the situations on the yard was that ever
a position that you were in
um i mean i don't
i wouldn't say that um i usually like i
said i'm not trying to drive no airplane
and [ __ ] i'm a passenger and i'm just
you know trying to get to our
destination properly and that's about it
that's fair that's fair
um
you know when we think about prison i
always hear would hear crazy stories
about riots going on in prison like when
like you know
were you ever part of any of the or
witness any of that stuff yeah all of
that comes along with you know you being
incarcerated you don't even gotta go
look for it it's gonna find you
you know
it'll definitely find you you know a lot
of the a lot of times so i started off
going to a level three prison
which
level twos and level ones are a little
bit lighter on
everything
level threes and level fours are a
little bit higher on you know respect
level just you know just different
things so
i while i was there in the level three
prison you know a lot of people would
say hey look if your points don't go up
you're gonna get sent to like a level
two or a level one which you're not
gonna like being the fact that you
already started in a higher prison where
the respect level is much higher where
you know there's a lot more going on so
when you say points just so we
what do you mean points so we there's a
point system while you're incarcerated
it's like if you do good your points
drop so you go to a different jail yeah
they'll send you to somewhere else and
then like a less
security like a lower security or
whatnot if your if your points go higher
then you go to a higher security or you
stay where you're where you stay where
you're at depending on their their um
like their way of monitoring your points
so my points were going to drop because
i hadn't gotten no you know write-ups no
i haven't gotten into trouble so
a lot of people were like you might want
to you know spike up your points get a
little write up for this get a little
write up for that
and then i had an older homie that came
up to me and told me straight up he said
don't go
jack up your points it's going to come
to you when you least expect it you
don't need to your points are going to
come don't even look for it so and they
did i started getting write-ups for
[ __ ] alcohol and i don't even drink
start getting write-ups for this dad
that getting caught knives like just
diff all that stuff came on its own i
didn't have to go look for it so the
idea of like one like like not your mate
yourself but the idea of your peers of
getting your points higher to stay where
you're at is that based on just like hey
you're already here you're already
established you're comfortable you're
comfortable you know what i'm saying if
you go to a new prison you might need to
hit reset on start over politicking and
networking everywhere you go like i said
it's a difference if it's a different
ball game and like i said they want you
somewhere where of course
anybody in general not just
me or any of my friends or anybody in
general would would love
respect more than someone that's being
disrespectful or you know what i'm
saying so in those places the higher
levels of prisons there's more respect
that's fair um
i don't know did you see recently um
whack was on clubhouse talking about how
you would never sign a south sider did
you see that um i heard about it i
didn't really pay too much as many
attention to it i talked to him about it
a bit and he was just like you know i
obviously have mexicans i've signed he's
like but i was locked up for x amount of
years and you know we were at war and
like
i couldn't sign this outsider because
my comrades that are still incarcerated
will look at me a certain way right um
was that like like is that something
that as you know because i i feel like
i guess i never i didn't grow up in l.a
so i guess like the beef between blacks
and mexicans was something i never
really witnessed because it was never
something that happened in phoenix where
i'm from
but how serious like in prison like you
guys are enemies right i mean
in prison there's like there's a whole
new set of rules
nobody's really your enemy other than
you know what i mean it's just things
happen while you're in there and it
could be with
the officers it could be with another
race it can be with whoever it's just
not one certain crowd that you don't
like and wake up and and say hey i hate
these people because if you hate
somebody they're right across the day
room from you mm-hmm you can go get them
there's no oh i hate them but they can
stay on their side of the day room i'll
stay on my side it don't work like that
if i hate somebody i'm coming for you
you know what i mean and
as far as what you know whack 100 said
you know i i feel like every man has
their own opinion or every man has their
own choice if that's what he chooses
that's his opinion
so be it you know there's
people from
our side you know hispanics that don't
like blacks and that's their decision
you know what i'm saying like that's
their opinion it's just all it's just
all part of you know being a man and
taking these
these um
he's like uh how can i say like
stop taking everything to the heart man
you know what i'm saying at the end of
the day just roll with whatever's going
on and
do you
do you do you feel like it was a hard
for you uh at any point in time to like
leave behind that prison mind state
maybe like leave behind some of the
ideas and the politics that go into
being locked up in a position that
you're in and like and then also get out
be a free man try to stay on the right
track and also succeed in as an artist
right well it's always hard
being the fact that you know one thing i
can't give up is my homies i love my
homies you know and i still you know
associate communicate whatever you want
to call it with some of them that are
family basically they grew to be family
over the years it's like it's not about
us going to go look and try to find an
enemy now or oh it's us trying to sell
drugs now like now it's just hey what's
up my boy how you doing oh look today i
did this i did this music i did that so
like the the good thing about my homies
is they respect what i'm doing they
appreciate what i'm doing and you know
they still got love from me they haven't
switched up they haven't
you know basically like i've seen other
you know artists that are from certain
gangs that they can't go to their
neighborhood because their homies don't
[ __ ] with them like that
you know what i mean my homies do and
that's a blessing
you know what i mean and they see what
i'm doing they see that i'm doing
something positive and they they respect
it um
what would be your advice right let's
say you're talking to a kid who's from
where you're from and they're getting
mixed up in some [ __ ] that maybe you got
mixed up in and
you kind of made that mistake first
um how would you advise somebody to try
to like avoid right kind of make doing
some of the things that you did that you
know right i mean i feel like
i all i can do is give my advice and
give my you know incentive on what
can happen if they lead and go in that
route i mean it's their choice to make i
can't make the choice for them
um and i'm gonna respect whatever it is
they decide to do i'm not gonna sit
there and nag or try to preach or
because it took me a lot to get to where
where i'm at in my my mind state it
wasn't overnight and it wasn't somebody
just telling me hey if you take that
road this is gonna you know i heard that
so many times and i just it went in one
ear came out the other i just kept going
work going for what i knew that straight
that's real um how long have you
actually been rapping like writing
rapping like how long have you actually
been like kind of applying yourself to
being just a writer right so i started
young like with with
like i love music so i started you know
when i was 13 years old before i started
going to jail and stuff like i would go
to like my neighborhood parties and grab
the mic and you know a certain part of a
beat like a bounce rock skate beat the
old school beat i would just sit there
and you know rap about neighborhood
stuff and gangs and all that kind of
stuff and i had the crowd of the people
dancing so i'm sitting there like okay
like they they really feeling this like
you know what i mean like i'm really
they're not just sitting here laughing
at a [ __ ] or else they wouldn't
even be sitting there trying to dance or
bobbing their heads to it like they
would have been laughing right you know
so i felt that they you know they gave
me that motivation to to keep pushing
and keep going with it and
like i said so much time in the system
that you know when i
when that whenever i would get somewhere
it's like
say if a riot did kick off in the yard
then we get locked down so all that time
locked down i sit and write music you
know write music i'll work out birdbath
do whatever it is to get through that
day but at least an hour or two hours
derocated to my writing you know i
didn't stop when i came home i had
six years or five or six years of no
books notebooks filled up i still have
them that i haven't touched that you've
never even recorded any of that stuff
anything from there i got hooks
i got you know verses 12 bars 8 bars 16
bar versus like i got music for days in
that folder in them folders and when i
came home i learned how to use the phone
right to write my lyrics so i just
pushed that aside and said okay cool i
can do it over here now i got
120 songs plus that ain't been released
that i just got sitting there like
that's dogs i got a lot of music you
know you mentioned a bird bath what's a
bird bath bird bath is when you're not
allowed to go take a real shower because
that cause you know you can't come out
of your cell so you got a shower with
that sink in that toilet that you got
right there you know what i mean you put
towels towards the door
kind of stop the water from going out
onto the tear because nobody likes water
on your tear you know what i'm saying
people try to fish people try to walk
through there they can't because there's
a puddle of water and soap which is
nasty it's all your dirt water
so you you know you put up the towels a
certain way to where you see which way
the water goes so if the water comes
this way you make sure that part is is
blocked in so the water stays in your
cell
you know you put up a sheet or a blanket
whatever it is to cover your cells or
your celly ain't watching you wash your
ass you know what i mean of course
soap up you know throw you get a cup
water you know pour water all over
yourself soap up whatever you can and
the same thing you fill up your sink
where you put a little piece of maybe i
don't know envelope or whatever that'll
hold the little holes down so the water
don't go down fill up the sink with the
water then you just dunk in your cup and
just pouring it over yourself you make
sure you shower yeah it's a shower but
it's called a bird bath you know what
i'm saying it's going to smell like [ __ ]
then after that you get your your towels
you pick up all that dirt water and just
wring it all out into your toilet
you know it's it's it's a little hassle
but once you learn how to do it and
they're refreshing
you know what i mean you're clean you
can lay back on your bed and smell good
like you know and then you would do that
only if you were under lockdown right
which a lot of the times we were so
sometimes that was almost every day
because i think they'll give you a
shower like every 72 hours 72 hours like
72 hours
and
it's like i'm not going to sit there and
wait for those 70 top two hours you're
gonna smell crazy i'm in the shower
yeah so especially if you've got a cell
mates
you're working now like you know that's
why you get that program you clean
yourself
you know one day he cleaned it one day i
clean it one day like you know we take
turns and [ __ ] and it's a it's like i
said the respect level is a lot better
when you're in you know
places like that what happens if you get
a cellmate and it doesn't work out you
don't get along with them
is it like
like what happens then um it'll it's
like a forced roommate you can't even
vet the guy like yeah i mean it all
depends you know what i'm saying there's
certain ways of of going about it and
getting you know your rooms
moved around and you know what i'm
saying you put with somebody you're a
little bit more compatible with or
somebody you know from the streets like
myself uh i kind of
refrained from having my own homies in
the cell because at the time i felt like
you know after a little while your own
homies get comfortable you know what i
mean like they know you from the streets
they love you and it's like
they get real comfortable they might
slack on the day they're supposed to
clean themselves you know so i kind of
just so that we could keep that same
love and same respect like i showed up
with other dudes that you know what i
mean i didn't know like that so that way
the respect stays
stays there that's interesting you know
um
so the last time you got out what was
for you like
the
i guess the thing that changed where you
really focused on staying out for good
and focusing on
the music [ __ ] like full time so the the
first time i like i told a couple of
people before the first time i came home
was in 2005 that was from the state
prison
and when i came home i had i just did uh
close to six years i came home and i
told myself hey
whatever it takes
to get some to get paid do it you know
what i'm saying whatever you need to do
get this bread go get it so i did but i
did that
like i told myself legal or illegally so
yeah i mean yeah when you say whatever
it takes
so i was running around acting a fool
getting money
you know on the streets but it was not
legit you know what i'm saying i was i i
was acting the fool like i said so
i seen that i was able to do that and i
went back to the system i went back to
the feds you ended up you ended up
getting caught up for the ways you were
getting money
why did you get like what would you get
caught up doing i got caught up on on a
rico racketeering extortion a conspiracy
case and when ended up going to the feds
and [ __ ] you know for phone calls you
know talking about dope whatever you
know what i'm saying i ended up getting
caught up well anyways after that you
know now i'm sitting in you know federal
federal custody
uh doing my bid and
telling myself in my mind if i told
myself the first time that i'm gonna get
out and get paid no matter what it took
i'm gonna get it and i did that i said
maybe i could do that again
but righteously the right way i'm gonna
get out get money get paid but legitly
through my music and just go as hard as
i went
back then
now but with this
and hey
it's working i did it again have you
ever thought about um
because i feel like people would pay you
to come and speak to them right i feel
like you could be like a
motivational speaker man
no like i always see like um
there's like motivational speakers who
have crazy backgrounds you could go
speak at conventions you could speak a
leadership [ __ ] like i feel like you got
a crazy story i actually did that a
little bit i did that a little bit with
a company that i worked for when i first
came home from the feds
um they had me going to like schools and
talking to the kids
and it was funny because you know a lot
of the teachers would sit there and look
at me like oh [ __ ] who are we bringing
into our school but when i leave
those kids would be asking for me
they would get at you know my boss where
i worked at and ask him hey is he coming
back the teachers would be like we need
him back because
now this kid that didn't listen to me
for all these years is listening to me
and now this like they really enjoyed
what i brought to the table and funny
that i ended up catching a violation
um through my probation officer that
that you know
went and said that oh i made an album
while i was on probation which i
shouldn't have done the baldacci code
which is my album
um well you weren't even allowed to
record nah because he said that when did
you get the time to go record that when
you're supposed to be at work when
you're supposed to be this when you
don't have money for this or you don't
have money for that like i came home
my music carried
the money yeah like i didn't need to
have money people were hitting me up hey
come record at our studio we got you you
don't got to pay nothing like that type
of [ __ ] that's what they didn't
understand he was looking at my social
media and like you got a bentley on your
last post you got money to pay for these
these house arrests or this dad like i'm
like bro that's not my bentley and once
you see that
you know once you look at that and
picture that like that you're you're
turning into a fan bro like you know
what i'm saying like this is just part
of i can see yeah i you know what i mean
like this is what you're what this is
what also people are you could record at
home in your closet for [ __ ] right
three hundred dollars at guitar center
right and he didn't understand that you
know i had to kind of explain to him so
he finally
took me to jail for that and took me to
jail for being with my son's mom because
she was on on federal custody as well
but when we got there she was pregnant
my judge was like okay what is he here
for he's like oh you know he's here for
the violation for recording this album
and talking about gang stuff and murders
and whatever he thought that i was
talking about he just put his little
concoction of stuff in his brain right
oh he's this is what he's talking about
then he said oh he's also in violation
for being with
the kid's mom or the my pregnant baby
mom and
for missing a drug test so those were
the three things that i was there for
she kicked out two of them she kicked
out the main
cd
album thing she kicked out the baby mama
thing and all she left me was the
mystery test he
asked for a year
added to my
probation and a year more in custody he
wanted me to go back to jail so she said
you know what uh i have
27 letters from teachers and from all
these people saying how he's such a good
guy and how he's doing so well with
himself
should i believe the 27 letters of
people or should i believe you like
she's like i'm kind of
like struggling to see who i'm gonna
believe and also i believe it was uh a
comment on social media that kamala
harris had left
um she left a comment on your social
media not exactly mine but the people
that were like
that i worked for before
they um they put up a post of me going
to speak to the kids and she left a
comment like saying that's great or
that's awesome or some so you know of
course they screenshot it they use that
towards my advantage as well she she's
seen that
she's into the time that kamala harris
is the this was before she's the
attorney general or district attorney or
something i don't think she was what she
is now right right well she definitely
wasn't vice president but at a point in
time i think she was attorney yeah i
think that's when she was attorney
general or something like that so they
said she locked up a lot of people yeah
that's crazy yeah so she i mean it
helped me in a sense though that's great
going forward you know um
the the judge she was a sister you know
what i mean so she was cool she was
actually taking the time to
read she actually applied herself to all
of the information like some judges will
just look at the probation officer look
at me
yeah
look at this guy yeah i don't care what
you say you got going like you gone so
that helped me and
instead of giving me a year in custody
and a year added to my time she gave me
90 days in custody and
termination of probation so that kind of
was a blessing it was the best because
you'd rather go knock that three months
out i was live
live free no reading a book yeah i mean
like i'm not even tripping and that
helped me because you know i went and
did it and when i came home i didn't
have no tail no worries you know what's
up y'all got to interrupt the bootleg
cab podcast we have a brand new sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go alright super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogie's double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly up to a thousand dollars so if
you put a thousand in they'll match your
thousand dollars and you get in on all
the action for super bowl 56 i mean
seriously
joe burrow versus matthew stafford the
rams are playing the super bowl at home
in la what does that even mean because
none of these home games i've been to
them
it's a lot of out
outdoor fans coming in the 49ers took
that place over twice in the last month
we'll see how the bengals fans show up
alright this is the most important game
of the year it's the biggest game of the
year and you can get paid by watching it
my book is giving you everything you
need to do it with that double your
money you can double your winnings and
the best starting point for the big game
is these super bowl prop bets they're
fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid ass
interception
probably probably
is joe mixon gonna score a touchdown
i like it i don't know get in on that
prop back action and uh listen even if
you don't pick on who's gonna win you
you could be a winner all right uh it's
a great look the prop bets are the most
fun for the super bowl so don't miss out
head to my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars by
using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast for three
years bro
of probation or actually four years of
probation i wasn't able to smoke weed
and that's my thing i smoke well like
i'm a [ __ ] weed head you know so
i had to
you know compromise i was smoking spice
oh that's just dangerous bro i would
pass the blunt to people and they would
pass out right next to me that's that
i'll grab my blunt bag and keep smoking
you were smoking spice like how often
30 blunts a day bro of spice spice
thirty blunts a day people that were
around me my brother he'll tell you did
you have any episodes on that [ __ ] i did
but not to where it freaked me out
completely because i already seen what
it was doing to everybody else so when
they'll hit me in that little weird
state i just kind of ride it out and
just sit there and wait and be like yo
what what is that weird state feel like
because i think with we think of spice
it's like an adrenaline when we think of
the guy in miami who [ __ ] was wilding
out when he bite somebody eating
[ __ ] yeah i ain't never getting
but like what like what's like the
craziest spice like what is that what is
that this is just a crazy adrenaline
that i got while i was you know smoking
um
i've been with some of my homies and
we're smoking and my homies get a whole
picture in their head like we're they're
about to kill us take me home type [ __ ]
and i'm like bro we're good we're at the
gas station we're just gonna get gas
don't trip
and i'm tripping i'm tripping type [ __ ]
so i know it affected different people
majority of the people that it did
affect while i was with them their first
instinct like their first thing that
came to mind was i'm gonna die
they would always grab their head and oh
my god i'm about to die and i'm like bro
you're not just chill you know what i
mean you never felt that way mm-hmm i
got to where i mean you were smoking 30
a day man so i built a hell of a i'm
glad you're still here but you know
thank god man i was everywhere in
neighborhoods that i'm not supposed to
be in standing in line trying to buy
spice to where the dudes will come in
and be like you from florence and i'm
like yeah
you know you're not supposed to be right
like yeah i'm just gonna get something
from the store real quick i'm good like
so you were like seeking out spice
everywhere no matter where you had to go
type [ __ ] and it was funny because it
started becoming illegal so you go to
like one little smoke shop and they'd
have it on the level like oh we don't
got it no more but you could go two
blocks to the right make 11 words right
there and then you're like oh i'm on my
way like now i know people who got
locked up uh a smoke shop owner in
arizona got locked up because he was uh
i think he was like one of the
distributors of that [ __ ] a lot of
people i know who are like
in that industry got got hit with some
serious charges and that dude had to go
to jail for a few years over spice bro
i've seen people just take a hit and
just start having a seizure right next
to me where i'm like
what the hell yeah it kind of reminds me
of like uh i guess in the 90s when
people were doing angel dust right right
and it's funny that it lights basically
like the same like it flames up it's
something that whatever chemicals it was
that they were putting in there they're
not good for people yeah no [ __ ] and on
the back on the bag and the packaging it
says not for human consumption that's
what a lot of people will get mad at me
about they're like you reading that what
are you still doing you know
but i'm like i can't smoke weed this is
the closest i get to weak because nine
out of ten times that i smoke that blunt
it makes me feel like i'm hot like i
smoked a blood wheat wow
the spice
that's [ __ ] crazy and then they're
not pissed testing you for spicy no it
don't come out don't come out on your
chest so after all that was done you
know i got off probation i went straight
back to weed immediately cut the other
[ __ ] away and you know did you were
you ever involved in any other drugs
like did you ever have any any errors
where you were [ __ ] anything when i
was younger you know what i'm saying i
tried stuff i tried smoking primos i
tried all the little
all the little [ __ ] you know what i
mean but it's just nothing never stuck
with me nothing ever
caught my my attention like that and i
just you know that's not me i know some
people like will go to go to prison and
like because of the time or because of
boredom or whatever they pick up like
heroin
it happens it happens you know i i
myself
chose not to i'm the type of person that
if i like something i like it and i'll
keep doing it right so i don't want to
even test myself like that you know yeah
so i'm happy that i like weed because
i'm gonna keep doing that you know what
i mean hold on real quick yeah my dad's
called me six times in a row you're good
oh my dad's got covered oh man
i'll call you in a sack
well
papa's got coats
shout out to my dad anyway um
we're talking about spice um yo help me
understand something because something
that i had zero
well now i wouldn't say zero clue about
but
after i moved to la i guess i was
lightly
put on my radar about like something i
really didn't know much about because i
always would hear about
cal are mexicans from from northern
california and mexicans from southern
california in this huge beef what's it
northenos and well
yeah yeah what is what um
that's
like kind of break that down for me man
because i'm not very like
i think a lot of people might hear about
that but if they're watching this this
is pretty crazy like it's like a serious
thing right i just feel like you know
everybody has their own side where they
grew up you know i'm saying they grew up
in a certain part of california we grew
up in a certain part of california
simple as that there's like no other way
really to explain it so if a northern
california mexican gets locked up in
southern california do they have to go
to like pc yard or are they or is it is
it is it bad for them it's like
it's like every everything else you know
what i'm saying it's like when you get
put in a position where
you can't do anything about what you're
going i'm sure that the it's the
officers that make their calls on
whatever they you know what i'm saying
whatever they choose to decide they know
where people belong and where they don't
you know what i mean that's crazy yeah
and then
do those politics spill outside of
prison
um bro i'm gonna be honest with you
there's so much like
stuff that has changed over the years
that i haven't been in the system to
kind of understand what's the latest
like that you know what i mean like it's
just it's just a life of
you know constant constant moving and
you know what i mean just like i said
earlier just gotta roll with the punches
and
is going on is what what's going on you
know what i mean it's like we we
just adapt basically you know right um
when did you first start uh
getting a tattoo in your face in your
head man because
some of these tattoos look new some of
them look very very old right right i i
um was
when i first got i had got a f13 on my
chin when i was like right before i went
to juvenile hall i was about 13 years
old i put a f-13 with a la on top of my
chin
um i had that i was i went to that
before i started tattooing like my whole
body like i still had some tats on my
body but
i went to the face like right away and
my
my grandma she was like oh she seemed
that when i was younger i used to go
stop by this this jewelry store and
always look at this chain that i liked
you know i would just go look at it ask
them to try it on i didn't have no money
but i would still go look at it and let
me see that chain and try it on and
they'll put it back they knew damn well
that ain't no money they're like he just
here looking at that damn chain so she
came up one day and told me look if you
take off that tattoo on your chin i'll
get you that chain
so i was like all right but i still
didn't even think about it until you
know being in the system
um before i got i came home one of the
times i had a court order for them to
take it off and i had to go through
homeboys industry to where they were
gonna
excuse me erase well you know to the
laser technology yeah and
you know i reached out to my grandma and
i told her hey i'm gonna take it off
then so i could get that chain but i
really had to take it off like
you know
so she bought me the chain
i got the laser tattoo removal
and then i started getting more tattoos
on my face and then she was like you
worked me basically like
she's like i told her i you told me just
to take off that tattoo you didn't say i
couldn't get a new one i can't get some
more so
you know it turned out like that after
that she was just like she wasn't
trusting me no more when they came to
that [ __ ] you know she's like nah but
yeah like um i started young with the
tattoos on my face 13 14 years old
was there uh i mean when you have
tattoos like you have i'm assuming that
there's some that you regret is there
any tattoo that comes to mind that you
regret more than others um maybe like
female names and [ __ ] over the years we
young and dumb and
you know what i'm saying in the heat of
the moment what are you like go get your
name tattoo tomorrow right you know like
but now it's like
i just i just plaster over those
[ __ ] now like ain't no
ain't no biggie i feel like what's dope
about like your your appearance is
first of all it people are intrigued i
think when they see you right they're
like yo who's that right like who's the
guy and then they hear the music they're
like oh [ __ ] right
and then i also feel like you could
[ __ ] be in any [ __ ] movie like so
many people have been telling me bro
you're missing out on all kinds of
acting bread i started to have when i
first came home from prison i started
doing the whole um
what was that i mean you're going to get
typecasted right no yeah you're going to
be you're going to be like the big homie
in the hood or
they're always going to choose me for
certain certain roles for sure but [ __ ]
though
the money's green when i first came home
it's like i didn't have a car so it was
hard for me to get from point a to point
b i was sharing with the girl that i was
with at the time but she also had to
work
so it was like some days i couldn't make
it sometimes i could so i think the
central casting kind of got tired of me
pulling up late or not oh okay so that
so you just you would have hard times
getting to like right locations and
stuff like well now it's different you
know i got my own stuff and it's like a
lot easier but
maybe i would have to reapply or
something you know what i mean but yeah
man i just seen recently that uh a lot
of people started tagging me to uh this
uh
all hell the king i guess it's a disney
movie that i came out in so they're like
damn you're in the disney movie what the
[ __ ] like you know people tagging me oh
[ __ ] i didn't know and we did that like
six years seven years yeah wow
and then obviously ballet originals
thing was dope oh shout out to shout out
to estevan and
mr cartoon like that was a dope they
definitely made that happen bro you know
i was appreciative 100 um
you uh
you know i told you when i first kind of
got put up on to you you had linked with
yellow wolf yeah um which is also kind
of he's heavily tattooed but also kind
of random
right you guys ended up it's i mean i i
think you've told the story before
essentially he came he he was looking
for a place to shoot his show yeah that
came to your neighborhood you guys
connected
bonded ended up doing some music
um who are some other artists that like
you
would want to work with and some people
might not expect you'd be like you know
working with because i think the yellow
wolf thing is is one of those yeah
yellow wolf was definitely like a a
surprise to a lot of people and like i
said it was one of the artists that i
kind of
you know uh spoke into existence from
being incarcerated listening to him to
where i told myself i'm gonna come home
and i want to do a track with him right
and it happened same with crooked eye
you know shout out to frank nitty the
homie frank nitty plugged us up and
made that happen you know what i mean we
we
we had a nice little session in the
gritty ark studio and you know got got
to know crooked even before that the
fact that we did the track
prior you know times prior than that we
would be in the studio vibing out and
you know chopping it up and real cool
people solid and humble you know
um honestly myself i think i want to do
a track with 50 cent that'd be crazy
that'd be insane only because i listen
to like his music that's basically like
a lot of the music influence that i used
to you know
listen to and it's like i got out and a
lot of people like when i drop hooks or
when i drop certain songs they'll be
like that cadence reminds me of
that right you know and i'll be like
maybe it's because i listen to them so
much i don't know you know i'm creating
my own music so it's like i don't feel
like it sounds like anybody in general
but then again the fans and the people
that are listening are the ones that
right right it's their opinion yeah i'm
saying you uh also i heard a few of the
records uh you did with the homie chris
coke from arizona oh yeah i don't know
when those are going to come out but
they're crazy yeah no definitely he's
amazing he's he's a beast man i gotta
give it to chris lyrically he's a
[ __ ] monster one of my homies mommy
scrappy had tagged me to something that
he you know he was doing and the scrappy
was like man check this fool out my boy
he's dope so i listen
i'm like damn he is dope you know and
for me to
come off of my not i don't want to say
like
like my my high horse or anything but i
feel like you know you got some status
you're doing this
already two words like i don't have to
go listen to every single thing that
people throw at me right so it's like
for me to come and listen and actually
feel like oh bro's dope like it's it was
something to me you know so whenever
that happens i usually hit my boy my
manager john and tell them straight up
like hey
find this dude for me you know get at
them let's work
we got to pay for a studio if they got
up whatever whatever it is just let's
figure it out
let's make something happen so we
reached out to him and he was like more
than happy to do it because he had
already heard of myself as well too so
he's like
you tell me when and he came out yeah he
came out to freestyle on my show yeah
yeah he booked the studio yeah it was
dope and i was like oh yeah nice you
know so we made it happen and we got a
couple tracks in we actually recorded
like four songs that night yeah yeah
yeah yeah i heard i think i heard almost
i think i heard all of them yeah we were
like back to back with it um
oh it's good it's fine it'll pick up
oh oh on the camera okay okay
there you go
i like that
that's why he's the manager all right um
so
just right now i feel like we're kind of
in the middle of like a a renaissance of
like mexican rappers right i feel like
when i first got on the radio and when i
was growing up it was like mc magic
little rob like
obviously baby bash was doing this thing
but i feel like right now there's so
many
dope mexican mcs artists that are just
killing it on all levels right um you
know snow the product was just nominated
for latin grammy um
you know we can go up and down i mean la
is kind of the epicenter of like where a
lot of these young kids are really
killing it and in latin hip-hop scene
just in hip-hop and they happen to be
mexican right um
how do you feel about like the current
state of like uh mexican rappers
um man i love it you know i respect the
fact that everybody's out there trying
to get where they where they feel they
need to be or people that are just
pushing and
going for what you know what we've never
really been able to accomplish
um
which is opening that door for you know
the mexicans and for the hispanics and
you know people that have been trying to
do this for us for years you know we've
had episodes you know kid frost like of
course yeah you know what i'm saying
that people that did get their
their time to shine you know what i'm
saying but i feel like the door wasn't
completely kicked in forever i mean it
was always like one or two guys at a
time but i feel like now i mean i can
think of like 25 dudes off the top of my
head that's the difference now and then
i feel like social media and everything
else has brought that
for a little made it a little easier for
us to be able to you know show
showcase what we got and and
learn from each other which not
everybody's gonna sit here and tell you
that they that they learn from each
other but
if i see a dope artist that i can learn
from i'm definitely gonna soak up game
i'm definitely gonna appreciate whatever
he's putting out there you know
everybody out here got their chests out
and think oh i'm the biggest i'm the
baddest and that's why i don't fall into
that
category with my mind state i stick to
what what myself
my boy peter built which is jr for my
label like everybody that's from my
label jokes you know um just just just
everybody that's on
the team and on the squad
i try to push them to push me if that
makes sense like you know i'm trying to
like at the same time
they're working on stuff i tell them
don't get caught up with waiting on me
you know what i mean keep doing what
you're doing
keep doing what you're doing you guys
might pop before me who knows
[ __ ] then you're gonna have to bring me
i'm gonna bring you if i pop like
it's just a it's a square you know what
i'm saying and at the end of the day
it's like
we got to cover every corner in that
square and
that's how i feel like it needs to be
done
you know help each other help yeah let's
help you know what i mean um
tell me the story about when you were
shot was it five times by ak yeah five
times with ak i was
uh 18 years old um
wrong place wrong time type [ __ ] parked
in in the driveway and you know
two people came up and sprayed up the
whole car bro we had 36 36 holes in the
car
how many people were in the car three of
us anybody not make it
i'm the only one that got hit oh [ __ ] so
there was hoes throughout that whole car
um you know my brother was actually with
us my brother was in another
car and behind us or whatnot
um it was it was tragic bro you know
what i'm saying it was something that
you know i relive
every day because i'm still dealing with
pain i'm still dealing with
issues from you know that were caused
from that i got hit two times in my back
two times in my side and one time in my
arm i'm missing a kidney a spleen
half a liver half a pancreas
both my lungs collapsed
my aorta was torn completely
they had to um reconstruct it
um i was in a coma for a month and a
half it was insane my mom would be by my
bedside
the girls that i was messing with at the
time were by my bedside like my homies
would all pull up like at one point the
doctor came out with my bed after the
first surgery and seen
300 people there and couldn't believe
that there was 300 people even in the
hospital right he's like all of you guys
are here for bed one and they're like
yeah
he was like wow he's like well let me
tell you exactly something he wants to
live he's fighting
so the first surgery he's like but i
can't promise you the second surgery is
gonna go the same
when i came out of the second surgery he
told my homies
he's here he's going to stay
and they went crazy they want to go
barbecue and do all kinds of [ __ ] they
want to party you know
is that the only time you were shot yeah
there's only time that's that was more
than enough that was more than enough
right
that's some real [ __ ] damn
yeah i was yeah and then uh yeah they uh
so i had um these bunch of different
you know little machines
tagged to me and one of the nurses came
into the um
to the room where i was at
and i couldn't talk because i had a tube
like you know in my throat and my side
of my um
right here my like under arm yeah just
tubes everywhere basically and i
couldn't really speak i couldn't speak
at all um the lady came in and was like
oh i'm gonna take you off of these
machines i'm gonna try to walk you and i
had just got shot like a week and a half
before so i was like [ __ ] me like i was
looking at her like
no like the only thing i could do was
kind of you know shake my head kind of
get her to understand that i'm not ready
to walk she's like oh you're fine she's
unplugging all this [ __ ] and i'm like
like no like you know what i'm saying in
my head i was screaming but i couldn't
right say nothing
so she took me off of the bed sat me up
and i guess when she sat me up uh air
bubble wrote uh like right rose to my
into my brain oh [ __ ] so i passed out
i passed out when she did that because i
didn't i didn't know what was going on
but the air bubble
rose to my brain and
it caused
something up there to where it made me
pass out um the doctors came and tried
to get me back they couldn't then the
doctor finally got me back with
something exceptional stuff so
um when i woke up he's like move your
right hand so you know i move my right
hand he's like move your right leg so i
move my right leg and he's like move
your left hand and i tried and nothing
would move move your left leg it
wouldn't move either it was parallel i
was paralyzed from half of my
half of my body
so they had to take me to long beach
memorial hospital and they put me in a
diverse tank wow which i guess the
divers when they dive too deep they get
those air bubbles
so they they deal with the same stuff in
a different form so they put me in a
diver's tank to where it was like at an
angle my feet were towards the ground my
face was like
up here
um
they put i still remember they put on a
movie they brought like a little sliding
screen with a movie and uh they put on
something about mary i remember they
still put that movie on and then like
within three minutes to four minutes i
was out so i guess they gassed that like
tank wow you know they put you to sleep
so put me to sleep and then i guess they
turn up the pressure while you're
sleeping
they brought me out and he's like move
your right hand i moved him right leg
moved it move your left it wouldn't
budge it's like thrown back in so they
put me back in there
i don't know i don't know how long i'm
staying in there again but they put the
same movie back on
turn the gases on or whatever and oh
when they finally pull me out he's like
move your left hand
i was able to move my left hand and move
my leg out to there crazy for sure for
sure i had one of the top 50 doctors in
the world his name was dr ascencio he's
from brazil wow he was at usc hospital
he definitely is a blessing and you know
if i ever had the chance to
show my appreciation i would man you
know what i'm saying this is definitely
a blessing to have been under his yeah
cause you you know if you don't have the
right doctor they might have just been
like oh you're [ __ ] that was what they
were saying when i was walking in
they're like this one's done and that
doctor was like nah bring him to me he
was just there doing like
a study or a seminar
that's the stars of liner man one of the
top 50 in the world bro that's big
that's big uh outside of you getting
shot i was uh obviously when you were 18
what's the closest brush with
a serious life and death situation you
had while being incarcerated
um
man i feel like every day is just a
brush with
being close to life and death because it
could switch from
all smiles to you know place being on
fire like it from one second to the next
you don't know what's gonna take place
i've seen people go in with violations
of seven months and then end up with
um you know the rest of their life
having to be incarcerated like it
continues to happen in jail yeah
anything can happen at any time
just never let your guard down and just
you know
is it hard to let go of that men's
mentality
oh very very i feel like
you got to want something
bad enough
to be able to and and it's never going
to go away you know what i'm saying it's
never going to go at the end of the day
it's like your mentality
is there still
now whether you choose to like mess with
the volcano or just leave it alone
that's where that's where
all of this falls in place like you know
i'm doing music
i left all the you know
the untempered with
like i just kind of just don't mess with
it and just keep you know keep my cool
and respectful and still go about things
the the way that i know that i i should
be going about things you know what i
mean like certain stuff that
even on podcasts like this that i'm not
gonna sit here and talk about you know
what i'm saying at the end of the day
it's like it's all respect but there are
certain subjects i won't touch and then
there's certain subjects that yeah we
could talk about because it's something
that already happened it's events in my
life of course you feel what i'm saying
um with your new album
you're we're going to have your manager
come in and kind of give us a little
breakdown of some of the business stuff
you guys got going on because it's
pretty impressive
i'm going to take a piss break yeah okay
and then we'll come back and we'll have
your manager hop on sounds good hey we
gotta stop the podcast man real quick
appreciate y'all for watching uh really
mean mean it subscribe like leave a
comment even if you're one of those
[ __ ] who leaves a comment you're
always interrupting the guest because
it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't know i
like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad
they got the wwe they got mountain dew
they got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
all right listen so uh i'm gonna let you
introduce your guy right here yeah so
this this is my boy john you know my
manager slash business partner um so
is this the label you guys have chatted
on there is that your your yeah
your guys created it together yeah
effort
it's it's effort
we just put the x in the middle because
you know at the same time it's f fourth
you know so it's still like kind of like
what did we do
to the past you know it's the f4
effort i can dig it i can dig it um how
did you guys meet
prison prison yeah so you guys were
locked up together yeah 2002
um
we
you know met each other we were two of
the youngest kids on that yard that we
were at
um
and just kind of clicked um
we had a uh
like a boom box in there with two tape
cassettes so somebody had rigged it up
to where
the ox plug was a microphone in there so
you would put
like an instrumental on this side a
blank tape that you wanted to record
over on this side play them and then
wrap into the box plug and we have tapes
like we would make tapes in there so
we're making tapes and sending them out
to the streets oh [ __ ]
um
he came he went home before me i started
a few years left when he went home i had
he went home at 05 and i started like
three or four years left
when i came home
he had got caught up by the feds so
you know i'm hitting up his grandma and
she's like he's busted again so
since i since i came home i was trying
to like link back up with him right and
he had you know the fed case going on so
finally in 2013
um
12 or 13 2000 no
2013 i came home
um
and uh i was cutting hair for a studio
so i was cutting hair for a studio
studio uh like or just here's a video
studio so they would do music videos
commercials share a barber
i was yeah yeah yeah so by trade i was a
barber so i was cutting hair and the
studio i worked for had actually
done one of his videos so he's showing
me like all the past projects that he's
done i was like that's my boy like can
we get a hold of him
so went through the channels he's in the
feds again i'm doing a violation
so
one day uh uh the studio hits me up to
come help him with the with the video i
pull up and he's there he just came home
maybe a week or two before
literally the next day i went and met up
with them and for the next three years
probably four years i saw him every
single day like we were together every
single day moving around doing this
music ten days after we linked back up
again i quit cutting hair at the barber
shop i was at and we started running
with this wow um and we've been
yeah we've been doing that since how
many years has this been since you guys
officially
2006 15 or 16
16 is when we started
started running so i came home in 13 and
he was still back and forth
during his violations so a few years
after i came home is when we finally
linked back up and we've been we've been
running since so you guys uh have the
new album coming out which is what
what's dope about it is
you guys aren't putting it straight to
the streaming platforms yeah now we we
did that with with the with the plan
with the plan b album that was kind of
our first
um
getting our feet wet into to doing
something ourselves like instead of just
recording the music and letting somebody
else figure so we had to figure that
album out from beginning to end
um
so we we did that it got a you know good
reception um kind of opened a few more
doors but we did see that that
you know
with the kind of music that we have in
the project that we're coming out with
streaming right away is not going to be
our our best uh option yeah yeah wait i
mean listen at the end of the day you're
doing this to try to support yourself
not only that yourself the the fan base
the core fan base that we have is strong
so
also we're thinking it more as something
for for those people that have been here
supporting
they're going to get these
this physical uh package that we're
putting so what is the physical package
and what's the name of the album give me
the whole the whole [ __ ] there's no
official name of the album it's a double
album there actually is i'm gonna name
it the face of la there it is
that's kind of what we were
what we were you know
so
also makes sense at your ig
you know what i mean so i wanna name it
that and
it's just some you know
i feel like you know i'm not only
it's not only me that's the face of l.a
it's like all of us are the face of la
we're from here you know what i mean we
all represent the same thing and trying
to shoot for the same
direction so it's like all of us are in
this together you know i mean and i'm
i'm gonna make sure this album speaks to
everybody and for everybody like the way
that people you know
relate to each other in certain
situations
you know huge a huge part of the music
industry in la has always been built
around artists
um
either speaking about the street life or
um in rare cases an artist actually
being from the street life it's mostly
you know an artist that grew up around
there that's kind of telling the stories
that they've seen and then they kind of
morph into that image of you know he's a
street dude um
we're kind of you know the face of la is
what we've been pushing because
everything that that the entertainment
as far as music has been based around
and even movies like la is shown as like
you know street culture gang culture
that's what draws people
to to la outside of you know hollywood
um
and for somebody to be actually from
that environment grew up in that
environment is actually you know
certified from that and to be able to to
come out of that and try to try to
showcase and tell his stories in in an
art form music um it's kind of like
coming full circle to where now we have
an actual representative you know kind
of like a nipsy right um nifty was was
did it the street way and he was a
street dude um and there's not a lot of
of those in this industry that we're in
that we're we're learning as we've got
more and more into this industry
um
so you know it's just kind of a
representation of
of
the la people like like
all of our friends even if they're not
from gangs they're
if they're hanging out with us they look
like us and they're gonna be
uh assumed to be part of what we're a
part of that's just like the the hip
culture in l.a is to look like like a
street dude it's been like that since
the 90s
um the style may have changed but the
the intention is still there like the
intention you know what's cool is to
look like you know like you're from the
streets whether you are or you're not
um and for us being street dudes we want
to look like we're not from the st i
mean we we're tatted up but we're trying
to you're trying to elevate yeah we're
trying to break out of that
um
so it's just been a learning experience
and
especially as two dudes that had no
you know music experience i mean the
fact that you're able to go from being a
barber to
straight to this and
even me going to being a barber was a
huge thing for me because i never
because that's legit money yeah it's
legit money i've never done anything
like that um
so it was it's definitely been a
learning experience i feel like like if
we had a little more knowledge we could
you know maybe done things a little bit
quicker but i'm happy with the growth
that we've had because it's been organic
and right that's a learning process you
know 100
um for people who
don't know what's the pat like there's a
package coming out is this is it on
february 1st no we're getting so we're
doing april first april 1st that's what
april fool's day man
explain how people are going to be able
to purchase the album and the form that
it's going to come in
so you want to go ahead i just was going
to say you know we're doing it on april
1st you know because a lot of people
joke around with that date and you know
take everything as a joke so we're
coming strong and want to make sure that
they see that we ain't joking
yeah
we ain't playing with this album you've
heard a few yeah a few tracks on it so
um
as we talked about before you got hit
five times with an ak so we're going to
do a physical album package that the
album's going to be on usbs and the usbs
are going to be shaped like ak bullets
it's going to come in an ammo box we're
also printing out
laser printing baldacci action figures
so the package is going to come with the
album the action figures and uh we've
been uh in partnership with a hemp wrap
company called billionaire hemp raps for
the last two years we've been developing
a product the product that we showed you
so
um we're gonna have two flavors of of
hemp wraps tobacco-free uh hemp wraps
with his face our label branded on them
they're all gonna be dropping on the
same day as the album so when you get
this package you'll get the box with the
with the ak-47 bullet usbs uh you'll get
the action figure and you'll get some of
the hemp wraps so
um this is kind of for our core fan base
that's been rocking with us give them
something that they can purchase and
have that's not going gonna be um the
same thing that everybody else has um
before we let the album stream dope
that's smart man that's right and then
uh there's a cookbook a jail jail
cookbook you're working on yeah we
wanted to make a prison cookbook like a
thousand or a hundred ways to make a top
ramen because there's so many top ramen
yeah it's inspired pretty much cuisine
prison cuisine is all based around
noodles top ramen yeah so what you can
do with the top ramen adding to it
make it spread make a sandwich whatever
yeah okay give me the uh if let's say
you're in prison what's your number one
meal you could cook up if if let's say
let's say you could cook a meal for
somebody from the outside they're coming
to visit what would be that one
thing i mean the cookbook that you're
like yo this is fire well if it ain't a
spread of course because there's plenty
of different ways to make spreads i'd
say a manwich they're called manwiches
it's where you take the soup
you leave the soup
where it's in the package you put hot
water in there let it sit for a little
bit pour out the hot water so you still
got the whole noodle that opens up
basically like a book and you put that
on the bread you know there's certain
ways you make the beans you spread the
beans across it you know you could use
little pieces of pepperoni cut little
slices of pickle you know whatever
little ingredients that you put a little
bit of the seasoning pack and you know
you put it together with uh pork rinds
and stuff like that and you get a big
old monster sandwich that tastes like
it's from tommy's wow
wait so the i still eat them yeah so
there's noodles inside of the bread so
it's bread noodles but the noodles is
just in the brick like how it comes a
square it's just loosened up a little
bit loosened up a little bit just cooked
like that yeah but it's still in there
that's a lot of carbs man that it
i'm not saying it's a healthy book but
that's something that you guys still
make well i still make them yes
yeah i made one the other day man i want
to say like a week ago i made one of
those girls why do you still even my
homie just came home a year ago he's
like why do you eat this [ __ ] i'm like
he's good
you can't talk
over the years i'd always have people
like you making that you just jinxing
yourself and i'm like why cause i'm
eating a soup like
what the hell does i gotta do i'm not
out here i think you should do a youtube
channel man instead
i mean do the cookbook but the youtube
channel if you do like a show the a
recipe a week man right that [ __ ] will
go crazy trust me the youtube money's
serious man right right that's a good
idea that's a good idea definitely
because because
people
unfortunately people don't
i don't think people really
go to cookbooks anymore yeah right right
they have to be like a digital download
or something well no they get everything
online i mean honestly they just go on
youtube now yeah right that's true
if you if you learned how to fix a sync
on youtube the other day exactly if you
started a youtube channel where you were
just creating content doing recipes bro
that [ __ ] would go crazy yeah
and then you have special guests come on
martha stewart well maybe artists who've
been in jail or artists that haven't
been just if you've got a relationship
with crooked eye or whoever have them
come on make their prison and then
everybody does it different you know you
make them you make them something and
then they try they taste tested on
camera that should go crazy yeah no for
sure that's a good idea oh yeah then you
might [ __ ] end up on vice man why
don't we just do that together
but i'm saying like you might get your
own show on vice yeah for sure for real
like yeah that'd be crazy and then if it
goes super crazy it's not a [ __ ]
restaurant never know what happens we
got a kitchen here we could start a
little corner man i'm telling you bro
like homie to the store right now
cookbook is cool because like you know
you'd be i mean i would just do a living
to run in that but to really maximize
like
that like a coffee table book just like
you're you gotta you gotta do the video
content no you gotta do it the right way
yeah can't do it where it looks all
half-assed and brilliant and [ __ ] yeah
you know
that'd be big honestly sure that's a
good idea definitely gonna keep that in
consideration yeah run that [ __ ] up all
right so april first the album's coming
out um when are you guys gonna do a
pre-order for it because i'm assuming to
get that much stuff made it's probably
uh the production is it's do you want to
get an idea on like how many you need to
get made are you guys no we've kind of
got all that that worked out we're gonna
do a very limited run um it's probably
gonna total maybe a a thousand pieces a
thousand pieces and how much is it gonna
be numbered oh it's probably gonna be
150 bucks for that package it's not bad
yeah 150 bucks sell a thousand of them
you got 150 bands yeah
just those collector those collector
action figures alone bro like those are
those are
um
and we're putting money into this like
those things aren't cheap yeah it's not
like you guys yeah yeah yeah cause it's
not like you're
you know well [ __ ] man april 1st uh is
there a website or obviously your ig all
that like where's the best place to um
stay in the know about so his ig is
always going to be the best because
that's where he's at mostly um we do
have a website the uh baldacci the
beast.com um that's probably gonna be
switching over to uh when we do the
album it'll probably just be like an
effort webpage um
uh
to we'll have a link though of exactly
where to go to we probably will have
pre-sales just because we're we're
getting finished with with everything
that we need finished to have the stuff
to start the prototype yeah design yeah
yeah that's more of what we've been
waiting on to
to even put any pre-orders out because i
don't have the
i don't have the action figures in my
hand yet right um so once we have
everything then then we can put out a
pre-sale link i think there it is well
look go support appreciate you pulling
up man thank you brother follow him go
go support the album check your boy out
the face of la just like that the face
of la shout out to bootleg kev man for
having us here let's go